you Brooks and Dunn have been doing it
for quite a while at Caesar's Palace but
I understand you have some big news to
break to Entertainment Tonight we're
gonna extend to our residency at Caesars
Palace into 2017 yeah and we're
releasing new dates so everybody can get
online we can look at Reba calm or go to
Caesars and get on their website and
check out the new dates and come see us
so you're a Vegas kind of gal going to
Vegas yeah and hanging out with Ronnie
and kicks who wouldn't there's so much
fun what do you love the most about them
they're mischievous little boys they are
so you have to make them behave I hope
no I tried it don't work so I gave that
up
bad dude they're very smart they're very
intelligent and they're creative and
they're fun to hang out with because
they like to do stuff that I will never
think about doing that you know like
Ronnie loves he's really big into
photography and Kix is just open to
anything you're so busy though I was
surprising when I heard you were adding
even more to your place I'm like Reba
how you doing all that why did you
decide you wanted to add in a more days
just cuz it was going so well it going
so well
love doing the shows with Ronnie and
kicks and that's not a place you can see
that is that the residency there at
Caesar's Palace at the Coliseum and in
Vegas so we loved it we were really
excited to come back
you